more evidence that the sinister tech
Monopoly Google is not on the level not
at all what it claims to be new leaked
communications from inside that company
show that Google employees discussed
suppressing conservative news websites
in their search engine right after the
2016 election in one post from November
9th 2016 a Google engineer called Scott
Baier called the Daily Caller and
Breitbart opinion blogs quote and said
the Google employee should reduce the
visibility of both sites in search
results compared to quote legitimate
news organizations other employees said
it was the company's job to provide more
quote context to rebut news outlets they
disliked Robert Epstein is a research
psychologist the American Institute for
behavioral research and technology and
one of the people who's paid closest
attention to the power that Google has
mr. Epstein thanks very much for coming
on tonight so Google has said repeatedly
that it does not manipulate search
results and yet this is not the first
not even close to the first piece of
evidence we have from within the company
showing Google employees discussing ways
to manipulate search results can we be
confident they're not doing it not at
all you know Google was extremely good
at keeping its secrets for almost 20
years but the last few months that has
changed and there have been quite a
number of leaks and we have seen a
number of internal discussions there
like the one that you just described and
there's simply no question that they
have very strong political leanings 95
percent of donations there go to
Democrats I myself am NOT a conservative
I really I kind of lean toward Google's
political views but it's it's
frightening to me because of what I
study day by day it's frightening to me
that this company with very strong
political leanings has the power to
shift millions of votes to shift
opinions on a massive scale without
people knowing that they're doing it and
without being accountable to the public
how can you have a democracy under those
circumstances where one privately held
company has the power to manipulate
people's behavior without people knowing
yet
well that's what I'm saying and that's
exactly what's happening here and the
situation gets even worse when when
these huge tech companies the two
largest being Google and Facebook when
they both have the same political
leanings so you know in that kind of
scenario we're talking about the ability
to shift in the midterm elections I
calculated upwards of 12 million votes
with no one having any idea that they're
doing this this is not like fake ads
which you can see this is invisible
manipulation I mean I literally have to
invent new names for the techniques
they're using because they've never
existed before so Google assures us that
they're not doing this because they're
good people much better people than we
are for example how can we know if
they're telling the truth and should we
believe them oh well they're they're
sure they're good people that's part of
the problem as they have a kind of
utopian thinking within the company not
just among the employees but you know
their top executives think like utopians
so there they would believe me they
believe that they are doing good for
humanity good for good for the United
States by imposing their values their
thinking on the rest of us the problem
is as I say that they can do it in ways
that have never existed before in human
history so I know that is you already
said you and I have different political
views probably don't vote for the same
people so you're maybe the person to ask
how can the United States Congress sit
back with evidence that democracy the
core idea of democracy is being
challenged by this company and not do
anything about it
well the Democrats aren't going to do
anything because these companies help
them obviously the Republicans don't
like regulation so we have a tough
problem here in the US
now the Europeans on the other hand you
know they they see these companies as
American and so there have been they've
been much tougher on them and I think
we're going to see we're going to see
some pretty drastic actions taken
against these companies by the EU in the
next few years and that could change
their ability to operate worldwide I
never thought I'd be waiting for France
and Germany to come to our
rescue but that's that's where we are
unfortunately right miss trypsin thank
you very much it was great as always
thanks Decker